hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about that glider okay let's cut
let's kind of go through it first of all
you have a hypothyroid case that's a low
thyroid that could come from a low
amount of iodine in the diet okay
now either you're not consuming in the
diet because it's not in the food
because it's a trace mineral and our
soils are so poor or you could be eating
certain foods that are pulling it out
okay so there's even medications and
drugs like sulfa drugs will deplete
iodine lithium will deplete iodine
perchlorate that's in the water supply
that's why you need a house filter that
will cause a depletion of iodine and
then thiocyanate that's from cigarette
smoking if you smoke that can also that
chemical can pull iodine out of your
thyroid and then also different foods
like yuca soy bean pine nuts
strawberries peaches pears bamboo shoots
sweet potato cruciferous vegetables all
those have the capacity to deplete you
of iodine so so it could be a thyroid
situation coming from a lack of iodine
or it could come from a liver problem or
you're low in bile because your gall
bladder is removed in which case you
can't convert t4 to t3 so that could be
the cause or it could be high levels of
estrogen a lot of women that are
pregnant and have a baby during the
process the thyroid goes down that's
because the high mountain of estrogen
that can block the thyroid regardless of
that situation what happens when you're
low in iodine you're not making the
thyroid hormones and so therefore the
feedback mechanism is going to go up to
the pituitary and tell the pituitary to
make thyroid stimulating hormone and
that hormone from the pituitary makes
the thyroid and large okay that's the
purpose of it so that sends back here
because we're not getting the feedback
loop because when your thyroid is
producing normal amounts of thyroid
hormone it should act as a feedback and
turn off the pituitary so it can stop
producing but it's not enough it just
keeps sending communication it's not a
little bit of a circuit and the thyroid
gets bigger alright then you have
Hashimoto's that's an autoimmune
situation where your Thyer
is making antibodies that are attacking
itself in which case it's going to block
the thyroid hormone so you'll have low
thyroid hormone low iodine sending a
signal back up to the thyroid
stimulating hormone or not sending a
signal back and causing this the
pituitary to stimulate the thyroid more
to make it get bigger to the same
mechanism but in this case it's the
actual iodine deficiency this is an
immune reaction this is usually created
by stress induced autoimmune type
problems most autoimmune is
stress-related in this case you would
want to take iodine and you would also
want to take selenium
okay selenium is very important in the
conversion process and also the
production of making thyroid hormones
it's part of a certain enzyme that makes
thyroid hormones also it's very
important in vitamin A to take vitamin A
if you're deficient in vitamin A either
this one or this one if you're deficient
about M&A you're not going to make
thyroid hormones that well so you need
vitamin A vitamin A is an animal
products it's not in it's in vegetables
as a pre vitamin A but not the actual
retinol which is the active form which
is mainly in color boil egg yolks and
grass-fed dairy products things like
that so or you might not have a
gallbladder and you can't pull in that
vitamin A so that's another source so if
you're taking selenium you need about
two hundred micrograms and by the way
what's really high in selenium is
wheatgrass juice which is interesting
okay so we got those two mechanisms and
then we have Graves which is a high
amount of thyroid hormone production so
it's a hyper thyroid problem so that
person is too much iodine okay so you're
not going to give more iodine to a
Graves type situation and the reason why
the thyroid is enlarging with Graves is
because the immune system is creating
another thing called thyroid stimulating
immunoglobulin T F I and that is the
thing that's making this get bigger not
the pituitary but this immune reaction
okay so you never want to give a person
more iodine or C
help if they have graves because that's
going to worsen it you never want to
give a person with graves like bowel
support or gallbladder support because
that will make more conversion and make
more hormone okay so these foods are
probably good not the chemicals but the
foods would be good for Graves because
it will lower iodine okay now I have a I
use a sea kelp from Iceland which is a
very pure organic certified seek help
because there's not many oceans left
that are cleaned so that one is very
clean it doesn't have any chemicals in
it it's highly pure and you would take
that in the morning
of course not if you have Graves don't
take it before you go to bed because it
increases energy okay so I just wanted
to kind of give you a background of what
is behind goiters and it doesn't
necessarily have to always be a hypo it
could be a hyper alright thanks for
watching